For the past two decades,
I've been professionally managing assets
for large financial institutions.
But you know, this wasn't my plan
when I first entered the workforce.
I was a 20-year-old dreamer
who wanted to change the world.
And so at first I entered a nonprofit.
And this was where I started
asking myself questions
about how we attribute value
to things as a society,
and how capital affects
our shared reality.
And this was what made me want
to enter the finance sector.
And you know what?
Still, today, I believe
that changing the markets
can be a way to change the world.
Today, among investors,
there are a lot of questions
about decarbonizing portfolios
and how to achieve net-zero.
But when I think about the intersection
of climate and capital,
I’m always asking myself:
What effect is this really
having on the ground?
Because there could be a profound
difference between investing
just to protect your assets
from the effects of climate change
and actually investing to prevent
those effects from coming about.
You could imagine creating a portfolio
that appears to be decarbonized on paper
but that doesn't have any real effect
on the trajectory of climate.
And I would argue that that type
of risk management on paper
will also one day prove
to have been just an illusion.
Because what the world really needs
is real decarbonization.
We need to decarbonize
the old economy that we have
and invest to create
the new economy that we need.
It needs to be an economy that emits
no more than it can remove,
and that does this in a way
that is net-positive
for the planet and the people.
(Applause)
Estimates suggest that it will cost
three to five trillion dollars a year
between now and 2050, to achieve net-zero.
Just to give you an idea
of how much that is,
it would be like investing
the entire GDP of Germany or Japan
every year, annually, for 30 years.
So financial capital
has a huge role to play
in our shared success
or our shared failure.
And achieving decarbonization in the world
instead of just investment portfolios
is going to require us to make
some very big moves.
First of all,
we need to focus on innovative
transformation across every sector.
And then focus even deeper
on the science-based transformations
that are required within each industry
so that every industry can become
clean and future-proof.
You know, nowadays there are some
green or ESG portfolios
that have been focused mostly
on investing in low-carbon
sectors like tech.
But what I think
we really need to do today
is start focusing on heavy sectors
like industrials, materials
and infrastructure,
and use our capital
to reward those companies
that are really focused
on deep decarbonization.
Let me give you an example
of what I mean.
The cement sector emits about eight
percent of global greenhouse gases.
And so a lot of low-carbon funds
will actually decrease
their investments in cement
and instead increase their holdings
in low carbon companies like, say,
social media.
(Laughs)
But in one portfolio
that I help to oversee,
one of the world's largest
cement producers
is actually our top-emitting holding.
But this company
has committed to achieving
a zero-carbon production facility by 2030
and net-zero firmwide by 2050.
Now, I know some of you may be asking:
Is this company greenwashing?
Are they really
going to be able to do that?
Will they do it on time?
But what I can tell you is
that the company's already making
significant investments
towards these goals
and as shareholders,
we're going to be long-term
capital providers
to stick with them and encourage them
to achieve these goals along the way.
(Applause)
In another portfolio
that I help to oversee,
we're focused on investing
in the innovations
that make this kind of ambition possible.
Like, investing in novel designs
for the kilns that produce cement,
which actually remove emissions
at the most intensive point of production.
Or like another technology
that actually takes captured carbon
and injects it into the cement
in a way that also lowers costs.
I think that these
are the kinds of companies
that we should be committing
our capital to.
(Applause)
And we need to get moving.
Institutional investors like me
will often wait for years and years
for new strategies to be proven.
But today investors really need
to start leaning into innovation
and aggressively scaling the very best
solutions that we can find.
And it won't be hard to find them
because the climate revolution is expected
to make the industrial revolution
and the information revolution
pale by comparison.
OK.
So secondly in achieving all of this,
the next thing that we need to do
is realize that our goals,
like poverty and climate,
are actually interconnected.
The climate transition actually offers
an amazing opportunity to be accretive,
both in terms of the economy and society
because of the very nature
of the deep rebalance
that we now have to go through.
So climate change affects
things like poverty,
it affects health, biodiversity,
our global connectedness.
And all of these things
affect climate change, too,
in fact, all 17 of the United Nations
Sustainable Development Goals
are interrelated and inseparable.
So we need to start realizing
that we can't solve
any of these things in isolation.
We need to align our decarbonization goals
with our social goals
to be able to achieve any of them at all.
(Applause)
Next, we need to realize
that our climate action
cannot be localized.
Greenhouse gases don't hover
over any one country,
emissions anywhere
means warming everywhere.
So for us investors,
we need to get over
our home-country biases
that cause us to allocate capital
often too close to where we live.
In order to increase investments
to emerging markets,
we need to first realize that two-thirds
of the remaining investments
that need to be made
to achieve the climate transition
will need to be made outside
of North America and Europe.
Whereas too much of our investments
are being made here today.
Increasing investments to emerging markets
will mean advancing innovative structures
like blended finance,
that can help to augment
public-private partnerships
and collaboration with development
finance institutions.
But you know what?
I think that we're also
going to have to make
some behavioral changes within ourselves.
Like addressing our ambiguity bias
that causes us to financially undervalue
anything that seems foreign or complex.
(Applause)
So I'm not as naive anymore
as I was back when I was 20.
But you know what?
I still believe that changing the markets
can be a way to change the world.
Achieving the climate transition
in a way that is just,
global and interconnected
is the challenge of our times.
And the finance sector
has a critical role to play.
But we need to do it in a way
that is focused on serious
science-based solutions --
not just in our investment portfolios
but out there in the real world.
Thank you.
(Applause)